so you guys are playing uh justin
herbert this week he's put up some
pretty good numbers so far this year
what have you seen from here on tape and
how impressive you've been with his play
so far yeah he's impressive you know
very talented player you know tall sees
things well has a good arm can certainly
make all the throws he's athletic
definitely escape the pocket smart they
you know do do a number of things the
line of scrimmage seeing check plays
audible against pressure you know change
plays against
you know check with me type situations
looks like he's uh like he's gonna be a
good quarterback for a long time a lot
to work with i know he's a smart
hard-working kid that likes football and
sure he'll continue to get better
as he has this year
throughout the course of the season
[Music]
bill belichick talking up justin herbert
the player that they will be facing this
weekend in l.a first of two consecutive
games for the patriots in the new
stadium in la they're going to stay out
there and then i'll say a whole week
forgot sunday it's thursday and then
they get to come home all right matchup
draft week 13. chris you have a question
for me to determine the first pikachu oh
i got a question for you herbert who
looks like he's gonna be the rookie of
the year uh at least for for my money
has 23 td passes all right baker
mayfield has the rookie record of 27
from a few years ago which rookie qb
last year led the nfl with 24 touchdown
passes hurry up hurry up hurry up hurry
up hurry up
[Music]
i'm trying to think of who the reason i
know i can't think of that you can't
come on
i know
can you think of him yet kyler murray
was a rookie
right but i i think that's the trap you
want me to say kyler murray dwayne
haskins i don't think he had 24. gardner
minshew didn't play enough the only
other one would be daniel jones
oh there's the horn there's the horns
see i didn't say my i'd say i learned
your trick you don't have to say final
answer you just throw it out as a
possibility that's all right that was a
real answer we'll give it to you we'll
give it to you look let me go let me go
to
kyler murray kyler murray and aaron
donald on the same field i would pay a
lot of money to witness that in person
because you know aaron donald is going
to be doing everything he can to try to
corral kyle murray we've seen teams over
the past couple of weeks put together
kind of a semi blueprint on how to slow
him down murray still got the shoulder
injury we mentioned quarterbacks who
were limited he was limited yesterday
with a right shoulder injury from two
weeks ago and uh yeah aaron donald the
best in the league maybe with the best
interior defensive lineman ever
trying to stop kyler murray at a time
when the cardinals are very very
desperate to get a win yeah they are
i mean good pick by you that's
definitely one of the most intriguing
ones to me of the week too and you know
with that front and aaron donald you
know floyd leonard floyd on the edge
some of those athletes they're
linebackers they have our fast kyler
murray couldn't run a lick last year
against the rams i'd have a hard time
thinking he's going to run against this
group again this year that'll be
interesting it really will be but i i
mike
i'm going to stay with the same game
because i'm afraid you're going to pick
it and i just so i gotta stay there but
hopkins and ramsay is something i'm
really excited to watch i hate to double
up on one game but i'm just you know i
like to win our drafts at least a little
bit and
that's arguably the best receiver in
football i mean there's no doubt he's
top one two or three i mean he's one of
those guys
jalen ramsey for my money is the best
corner in football that is going to be
fun to watch to me it really is and you
know we'll see what the health is for
ramsey but his ability to play on an
island and do special things like that
it's really made this cardinals defen i
mean this rams defense uh kind of play
it at a higher level i'm excited to
watch that one
yeah and again i'll check this injury
report but i don't think his name popped
up on there yesterday despite the
hip problem that emerged just before
kickoff on sunday and limited him to 50
of 72 snaps for me
something we talked about earlier but is
still one of the more fascinating
matchups of the week derek henry the
titans running back going against the
browns defense can the browns defense
slow this guy down he had a huge game
against the colts he was the difference
maker the prior week against the ravens
and if the titans want to move to nine
and three
he's gonna have to get it done and if
the browns want to show
that they can beat a good team they're
gonna have to bottle up derrick henry so
it comes down to what that browns
defense can do against the best running
back currently in football and a guy who
seems to be in the midst of another late
season push that could help him finish
with some pretty impressive numbers for
the year yeah i mean it's he's he's
amazing he really is and for my money
the the mvp voting right now would go
rogers mahomes derek henry and it's
really close between all three of them
that's where i would go so i'm with you
and that that matchup is awesome because
i was gonna go there too just to go rb
versus rbs right i mean you know you got
the one-headed monster against the
two-headed monster and the cleveland
browns over there too that's gonna be
fun to watch to see which group gets off
which running back has the big day um so
that that'll be fun i'm with you there
good pick all right um i'm going to go
to another corner receiver match up
i'm going to go to devonte adams and
darius sled i think there's we're going
to see a lot of that head-to-head come
sunday afternoon the eagles play
man-to-man we saw last week they put
darius slay on dk metcalf a lot
especially in any man-to-man situation
that's going to be the same case once
again adams is a different player than
d.k metcalf not the raw physical
specimen a little bit more of a route
runner catches more maybe contested
balls back shoulders things like that
but that for me will go a long way in
that matchup we know rogers green bay
like to feed adams they like to make you
have to react or play to him to get
other things open within their offense
if slay can hold his own i think that
can make it tough sledding for that
packers offense uh overall in the game
yeah and uh look that's the thing you go
all in with that risk that you guys can
hold up in man-to-man if cevante adams
plays like he has most of the year it's
going to be a long day for darius next
one for me
and
i i
there are better match-ups but there is
something to be said for what we're
going to see next tuesday night which is
dez bryant on a football field against
the dallas county i forgot about that
for the first time ever right and dez
had no catches last night but lamar
jackson should be back based upon when
he was tested last week when that
positive is the window's going to open
on sunday or monday for him to return
now i don't know how physically ready
he'll be for a tuesday night game but
moving that game to tuesday night was a
little bit of an extra bonus for the
ravens so jackson can be back and maybe
dez bryant can you know he's going to be
driven you know he's going to be
motivated you know he's going to be
focused you know he's going to be ready
and he's going to want to beat the
cowboys and again even though dez bryant
hasn't had huge numbers during his
limited time with the ravens that's just
must-see tv with dez bryant on the field
with all those guys wearing the silver
helmet with the blue star and he's not
one of them yeah
let's that's going to be it is there's
going to be a it's going to be emotional
i think for both sides there with that
too you know and and can they get des
the ball in that match up a little bit
to you know give them something to to
say to the dallas cowboys you know what
what do you say like you got to get over
under for how many receptions dez gets
this week uh in that football game
i'll go four and a half we go four four
against the titans i'll go four okay all
right i'm cool i like that all right um
i'm gonna go to a coaching match up here
monday night football and then really i
i it's a it's two on two match-up that
i'm really intrigued to there i i really
am and it's it's co it's coaches versus
coaches it's the mcdermott vs shanahan
aspect two guys mike that you know of
course i have great respect for i mean
shanahan i think's as good as anybody in
the game on the offensive side of the
ball and you know i've been kissing
mcdermott's butt for the last three
years because mcdermott's just their
defense has got their mojo and
mcdermott's just one of those guys where
you just go i don't know what the hell
they're doing but where they're trying
to throw the ball everybody's there
covering them so i'm interested in that
and then even the other side robert sala
versus brian dayball that is going to be
good too i mean is there's two guys that
i think should be towards the top of the
list for head coaching candidates next
year so um i'm excited for the x's and
o's of that one to see how it all shapes
up
yeah and uh when you said monday night
football my first thought was it's
coming from the steelers washington game
because we have a double header double
hex monday night
by the way jaylen ramsey not on the
injury report yesterday for the rams so
whatever that hip thing was it's
resolved since sunday he should be good
to go come sunday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports